iliza you know in the finale and all
things are relative on the hundred but I
felt like Clark relative to other
finales had some optimism you know when
when she told Ali we'll beat this you
know basically that we will get through
this so these are pretty horrible odds
Jason's mentioning but do you think at
this point Clark at least feels like
well we've got gone through a lot and
maybe we can do this too um I think it's
interesting because she's realized I
mean as Bellamy says at the end of
season three you don't look like someone
who just saved the world and she says
because I can't until like we didn't and
I I feel like it's going to be really
interesting to watch
a group of people humans trying to
survive again in a world that that this
is an enemy that we can't defeat so how
do we move forward and of course in true
Clark fashion that will be her trying to
get everyone on board but there'll be
some very different reactions I think
you would agree with that like yeah well
we're definitely gonna see like the
range of reactions yeah Clark will be
Clark and she'll fight till the last
dying day to save everybody yeah
transcending tribalism
realizing that everybody is her people
something that she learned from LexA and
I think that ultimately we'll see others
react in a very different way one of the
ways that we find hope and light and
some humor which I think the show could
use for sure yeah is we could use some
some people are just done fighting and
they just want to have our tea until the
end of the world yeah that too you still
have that was it that plant or fruit out
there they could take and yeah not yeah
that's only in the winter they believe
that was episode eight this room yeah
yeah it could be a room
now Ian you know Kane had such strong
resolve in season three he stood up to
pike
he stood up to Ally but then obviously
he did give in to save Abby's life and
then it was such a wrenching experience
we saw when they were brought out of the
City of Light at the end you know that
just seemed to rock him to his core how
much do you think that's going to sort
of stick with him going forward or will
he you know just have to keep going
because there's a lot to deal with
um Kane is fairly pragmatic even though
he's grown a lot over the seasons but I
think one of the things I like about him
is that he sees what needs to be done
and hopefully he won't delve too much
into the PTSD and and just you know he
has a good leader I would hope he would
put others before him and put their
needs and concerns before his and try
and lead people um out mm-hmm or away
somewhere somewhere uh Murray uh I'm
guessing that some of this the humor
they're gonna try to bring in a little
more the season might not come
immediately from Octavia given where we
left off she's in a pretty dark place
right now made this decision and
especially I guess the timing of the
decision might have some raising their
eyebrows so what do you think is her
next move given the way things ended so
starkly for her in season three um
Octavia trying to bandage the hole in
her heart by getting her revenge on pike
but as we know that doesn't quite fix it
or bring Lincoln back does it so next
season you're going to see Octavia take
a really dark turn it's possible to go
darker we always surprise you I strive
for dogs just that uh man Octavia is
gonna go ahead and do what she does best
which is killing people she's pretty
good at it and you might feel skilled
yeah
special skills on her resume
yeah assassin that's what you're gonna
see her do next season um and that's all
I can tell you or I'll have to kill you
and Lindsey Raven too went through a
rough season last year uh you know in
the final episodes though she seemed to
sort of get her old spark back being a
Ally free do you think you know she's
feeling her old self again maybe more
than she has in a long time
I think Ravens feeling ourselves um but
uh no thank you no one's gonna take that
out of context don't worry um but I kind
of think it's it you know it's not the
same Raven I think you know she got the
Ali upgrade so her you know she's
definitely like a Raven 2.0 but I think
it's I think it's even better than that
because I think she kind of went through
an evolution and almost like a
reincarnation of everything she went
through she's not only stronger mentally
and intelligently because of Ali and the
knowledge that Ali left behind and has
created in her brain but it's um but
emotionally and spiritually you know
she's been to hell him back in it you
know it was kind of boring to her so she
didn't die so I feel like she's a
totally different Raven on a different
level ready to take on the biggest enemy
yet mm-hmm and Chris you know Monty he
had some big personal losses last season
some of which unfortunately he had to
participate in how much has this changed
him you know going forward you know that
the character you know was a very it is
always been a very lovable and amongst
some of the hundred characters a lighter
character but do you think you can't
come out of this not very changed by all
that's occurred well um it's humanly
impossible to kill your mother twice um
but I will say that there has to be some
optimism involved after mom death one
maybe he would have collapsed after mom
death too I think he definitely would
have
quit but I think given the stakes first
of all he has a possibly blossoming
romance which is exciting for him and
also it's the last moment between him
and Jasper you really feel hopeful for
the first time in a very long time since
like mid-mounted weather that they're
going to be okay
so I think for him he's more motivated
than ever especially because of the loss
of his mother keep protecting his chosen
family mm-hmm and you know Richard I
actually would say your character in
some ways did have again all relative on
the hundred a lighter season and
certainly found he found someone he
found the the Bonnie to his Clyde that
he seems to really care for in a
different way than we've ever seen him
and you know is that been interesting
for you to explore that side of him
given what the character was when we met
him yeah 100% um I just got to take a
second though because I've been waiting
a long time for this moment what I'm
taking this it this is the most
beautiful sight these eyes I've ever
seven look in a way long time see on the
screen with a little comic-con face
behind me that's pretty damn cool but ya
know it's a for me that was such a
different part of Murphy because there's
always you know you look out for
yourself number one which i think is
fair in a situation like that but I said
this earlier in an interview man like
life's nothing without love once you
find that yourself doesn't really matter
anymore so I think yeah absolutely it
still matters to him but he found
someone you can kind of share life with
and for at least now and I love that for
him honestly I'm just really happy he
might be he might there might be for the
first time in my time playing Murphy I
can see the possibility of maybe a happy
ending for him
mm-hmm and that's really cool we'll see
yeah I spoke too soon okay she's dead
now Jason let me ask you about a couple
characters that at the end of last
season where their fate was a little bit
up in the air
we had roan dragged off we had Indra
severely hurt can you talk about these
characters and their status alive and
alive okay Rowan played by Zach McGowan
is actually joining the cast as a series
regular this year oh I think you guys
all knew that I'm getting it checked and
so he'll be back in a big way and Indra
was on the cross as we know because Kane
told Octavia in the scene in the finale
and yeah one of the first things we'll
see is Octavia you know figuring out how
to get down and finding her way to Indra
yeah so happy mid points for both of
those characters okay okay but and we
will we'll be seeing some more Avenger
than as this yeah for sure or sure a
Dean is amazing we have a deal with our
to do for a certain number of episodes
that's the way it works a little too
inside baseball but yes she'll be back
for sure I love her of that character I
love what she's never reveals about the
world and what that character means for
Octavia especially and then one other
character when asked about because she
made it bring a big impression near the
end of last season it was Luna we met
now obviously made a big decision to not
help them yeah but will we be seeing her
again well uh nadia Hilliker who plays
Luna will definitely be back as well she
was a breath of fresh air I love the the
sort of total 180 from everybody that
we've met so far in the rounder world
and her character will come into our
world again in I don't want to spoil how
she enters the scene but in a world that
is beginning to collapse environmentally
and you know the effects of the you know
what I think Ali mentioned black rain
and boils and all the plagues of the
Bible start coming down they're out
there on a rig you know so they're the
Canaries in a coal mine
and so we'll see her relatively soon
you